in areas where deer roam freely
residents must dress to protect
themselves against deer ticks that might
transmit diseases
this actually looks pretty good in areas
and we're talking about what what type
of areas where these are areas where
deer
roam freely we're starting with this
relative pronoun
this is this is the type of areas deers
areas where deer roam free this this
looks pretty good i like it as is and so
i'll go with the first choice which is
always the as is so no no change to the
underline let's just go through the
other ones to make sure that they're not
as good or nowhere near as good
so in
areas roamed by deer freely residents
must dress to protect themselves etc
this one isn't as good because it's the
this part right over here is that it's
in the passive voice instead of saying
dear roam freely we're saying roamed by
deer freely so it's it's it sounds a
little bit convoluted most writers will
tell you the passive voice you should
avoid it unless you really need to
unless it really does something special
to what you're writing and so i would
definitely avoid this because of of that
passive voice so b i'd rule out c has
the same problem areas freely roamed by
deer it's a little bit better the adverb
freely is in front of the rome so
they're closer together so how are they
roaming they're roaming freely but once
again it's in the passive voice freely
roamed by deer instead of just saying
the deer roam freely so i don't i don't
like that one as well these these are
both both of these are in the
are in the passive
passive voice which in general you
should avoid
areas in which there are deer that roam
freely
so the in which part is okay you could
you could replace aware with
an in
which where in this case the which is
the relative pronoun and we put a
preposition here to talk about well how
do we relate to the area are we doing it
on it are we doing it in it where are
the deer well the deer are in it they're
in which so areas in which deer roam
freely so this you could say in areas in
which deer roam freely the problem i
have
with this one is this part there are
deer that roam freely there are deer
that roam freely is much longer than
deer roam freely unnecessarily long
unnecessarily wordy and so if you can
get it across in a nice clean way you
should and so i would rule this one out
just because it's wordier
and a little and a little bit more
complex than it needs to relative to our
original our original clause year
areas which dear roam free so the
problem here is we we have we have the
relative pronoun which but we're not
saying how do we relate how do we relate
to those areas that we're referring to
well the the how in particular how do
the deer relate to them well the deer
are in them you need to put that in
which this needs an in
right over here without the end this
doesn't really this isn't right really
grammatically areas which deer roam free
no no the deer are in the area so i'd
cross that one out as well